this graph makes a lot of people nervous
why it appears to predict that America
is about to go into a recession it's
based on an economic indicator called
the yield curve so if you care about the
economy you should probably care about
what's going off with the yield curve
that's Alice Fullwood The Economist's
Wall Street correspondent and the reason
people get sort of so het up about this
is that each time the yield curve has
inverted it has immediately preceded a
recession in America in fact only on one
occasion in the last 70 years has there
been a false alarm and here's the thing
inverted in March of this year so what
is it about this curve that seems to
make it such a good indicator of where
the economy is heading the lion
illustrates the return or yield
investors get from investing in
government bonds from short-term
investments on the left to longer-term
ones on the right
usually the longer the time frame the
higher the interest rate as investors
demand a bigger return if they're to
lock their money up for longer however
if investors fear the economy is slowing
down then the long-term rates can drop
below short-term rates the curve inverts
so when the yield curve inverts
something strange is going on here's why
when the outlook is gloomy investors are
more likely to buy safe assets like
long-term bonds pushing their price up
so the interest rate for holding them
falls higher bond prices are also a
signal that there are fewer exciting
investment opportunities elsewhere such
as the stock market of course there are
plenty of other indicators you could
look at to get a sense of what's
happening to the economy a lot of people
look at the stock market survey data so
you can go out and ask businesses what
they feel you can look at consumer
behavior you could also look at sort of
various metals prices like if copper
price is a very high copper is an
industrial metal it implies that lots of
manufacturing companies are buying
copper to make goods
then there's the rate of change in
unemployment which correlates closely
with recessions and even monitoring the
number of times that newspapers
published the word recession can help to
anticipate a downturn but bear in mind
that when you're trying to predict a
downturn you're often trying to get a
read on people's expectations of where
the economy is heading which is why that
curve is so useful
everyone invests in the US Treasury
market from the Chinese central bank to
pension funds in Canada and Europe hedge
funds in America everyone is exposed to
and invests in the US Treasury market so
if you're looking for an aggregate
opinion of everyone in the world what
they think might happen to the US
economy and by extension the global
economy you'd be very hard for us to
find something more important to look at
than the Treasury market and the yield
curve but these are extraordinary times
for the US economy which is always a
dangerous thing to say but it really
could be different this time the US
economy has undergone a lot of very
experimental and sort of extraordinary
monetary policy over the last 10 years
in particular people highlight
quantitative easing quantitative easing
was a policy to stimulate the economy
after the 2008 financial crisis whereby
the Federal Reserve bought Treasuries to
reduce long-term interest rates some
experts believe it's distorted the yield
curve and some people argue that that
that means that longtime interest rates
can't quite signal what they used to in
the past they're no longer this sort of
clean look at what investors are
thinking about growth and inflation
because quantitative easing and that
process has sort of systematically or it
sort of fundamentally changed what
long-term interest rates show you
so should investors worried about the
inverted yield curve well you can debate
whether the yield curve inverting in the
u.s. in March of this year necessarily
means that there'll be a recession in
the US soon what you probably can say is
that it's not a great signal that growth
next year will be will be strong the
flattening that's taken place over the
last year suggests that growth should
slow from 3 percent next year to 2
percent in other words predicting
America's next recession just got a
little harder but the indicators are
starting to flash red